الجيش التركي على احدى المروحيات كنا قد
اقلعنا من قاعده انجيرلينك في مدينه اضنه
وتوجهنا الى هاتايا هذه الطائره تركت
حمولتها وهي الان في طريق العوده الى
مدينه اضنه كما نشاهد في هذه الصور
سوف يتم تزويد الطائره مجددا بالمساعدات
ومن ثم نقل هذه المساعدات الى المناطق
المنكوبه هناك الكثير من المساعدات التي
يتم نقلها من بينها الخيام
المساعدات الاغاثيه لوازم طبيه لوازم
الاطفال ايضا نقل الموظفين التابعين
للمؤسسات الرسميه الذين من شانهم مساعده
المتضررين في هذا الزلزال من اجل
العمل على التاقلم مع هذه الحياه بعد
الكارثه طبعا هذه المروحيه هي واحده من
كثير من المروحيات التي
تقوم بنقل المساعدات والتابعه للجيش
التركي هناك طائرات تابعه لدول اخرى مثل
الولايات المتحده وقطر وايضا هي تعمل هذه
المروحيات على مدى الساعات 24 هناك ما
متوسطه ما بين 60 الى 70 رحله جويه كهذه
طبعا المروحيه كانت تحمل هذه المروحيه
تحديدا
تحمل خيام
الى منطقه في مدينه او محافظه هاتاي فكان
هناك حاجه
للقيام في تلك النقطه وبالتالي يتم
التنسيق
للاحتياجات التي
طلبوها المناطق بين اداره الطوارئ الطبيه
وبين وزاره الدفاع
يبدو انا الطائره الان في طريقها للهبوط
في مدينه اضنه نحن نقترب رويدا رويدا من
قاعده انجرلك التركيه
نعم كان هناك ربما الكثير من المشاهدات
التي رايناها في القاعده وهذه المساعدات
هي جاءت من العديد من دول من دول ومن
المدن التركيه
الاخرى مثل انقره واسطنبول واسمير يتم
تجميع المساعدات في مدينه اضنه وتحديدا في
قاعده انترنت ومن ثم يتم نقل هذه
المساعدات الى المدن المناطق المركوبه في
المدن او المحافظات العشره الاخرى
او 11 باعتبار الى ايضا ضمرت الى هذه
المحافظات طبعا هذه مختلفه
النوعيات وكنا قد شاهدنا كثيرا منها على
الارض هذه هي مدينه اضنه حسن
الطائره الان تقترب من قاعده انجر وقد
بدات هبوط رويدا رويدا
بالنسبه لهذه المساعدات واستخدام
المروحيات في ايصال هذه المساعدات
يطرح السؤال حول امكانيه وصل المناطق
ببعضها بعدما تضررت الكثير من الطرق بمعنى
ان هذه المروحيات الان تختصر الوقت والجهد
لايصال المساعدات الى المناطق المنكوبه
صحيح حسن هذه المروحيات تعتبر شريان حياه
مهم جدا لتنقل المساعدات الى المناطق
المتضرره والمتضررين هي تختصر المسافات
ويمكنها ايضا باختصار الجهد كون هناك بعض
المناطق التي
احيانا تكون في الجبال ولا يمكن الوصول
اليها عبر الشاحنات التي تنقل هذه
مساعدات وبالتالي تقوم المروحيات تحديدا
بدور جوهري في هذه العمليه لسهوله تنقلها
بين المناطق وقبل قليل عندما نزلنا في
محافظه حطاي نزلنا فقط لثلاثه او اربع
دقائق كان هناك عناصر من الجيش التركي
ينتظرون الطائره وقاموا بتفريد الطائره
مباشره لتقلع من جديد وتعود الى قاعده
باضنه من اجل التزود في مزيد من المساعدات
هذه الطائرات حسن هي لا تتوقف هي تستمر في
عملها طيله الساعات 24
وذلك منذ وقوع الزلزال في محاوله لايصال
المساعدات الى المناطق المنكوبه نحن نعلم
ان هذا الزلزال ضرب مناطق واسعه
من المحافظات التركيه العشر اضافه الى
محافظه الى زين وكان هناك اضرار كبيره في
المباني هذه الاضرار من بينها كانت
الطرقات الطرقات لم تكن في الايام اليومين
الاولي اول يومين او الايام الثلاثه
الاولى سهله وبالتالي لعبت المروحيات دورا
هاما في نقل هذه المساعدات الى المناطق
المذكوره بسهوله حركتها وايضا لقدرتها على
حمل كميات لا باس بها من المساعدات ترى
الان في الصوره قاعده انجرليك ونحن قد
وصلنا اليها هذه هي القاعده التركيه
العسكريه الشهيره تعود هذه المروحيه الى
مربطها من اجل التزود بمزيد من المساعدات
ريثما يتم جدوله مسار رحلتها القادمه هذا
المسار الذي يتم تحديده بين اداره الطوارئ
والطوارئ التركيه وبين وزاره الدفاع
التركيه
يتم استقبال الاتصالات من المناطق
المنكوبه والحاجات من المؤسسات الرسميه
ويتم تنسيق خطه عمل تقوم هذه الطائرات
لنقل الاحتياجات الى تلك المناطق وبالتالي
باتت تعمل بظروف افضل مما كانت عليهم
السابق الان يفتح باب الطائره للتنقل ضمن
الانتقاء
ونحن الان وصلنا في طريق العوده الى قاعده
في مدينه اضنه التركيه
اذن هذه القاعده التي تحولت الى مركز
لتجميع المساعدات
ومنطلق للمروحيات من اجل نقل هذه
المساعدات الى المناطق المنكوبه
شكرا جزيلا لك المعتز بالله حسن من
علامتني
الطائره المروحيه التابعه للجيش التركي في
قاعده انجليك